[Música]
economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna me acompañan el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches como lo
mencionábamos al inicio del bloque de
noticias ese esperado acuerdo entre el
Reino Unido y la Unión Europea por fin
tuvo lugar de qué se trata ampliemos
bueno para entender este nuevo tratado
debemos remontarnos al inicio justo
antes del brexit cuando la venta de
bienes y servicios entre Irlanda del
Norte y la República de Irlanda se
realizaban con pocas restricciones ya
que ambos territorios pertenecían al
mercado común europeo y seguían las
mismas normas pero cuando Reino Unido
salió de la Unión Europea tuvieron que
realizar nuevos controles comerciales
pero por el pasado conflictivo ninguna
de las dos partes quería que esos
controles se realizaran en la frontera
porque podrían poner en peligro el
acuerdo de paz entonces la aduana se
trasladó al mar que separa la isla de
Irlanda con Reino Unido pero creó muchos
problemas y también mucha burocracia
tres años después la Unión Europea y
Reino Unido acordaron para Irlanda del
Norte Un nuevo acuerdo que un sistema de
dos vías para el comercio entre las
Islas el llamado acuerdo marco de
Windsor que firmó el Primer Ministro
Richi sunak y la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Legend es un
punto de inflexión sin duda para el
comercio entre los cambios más
importantes es que se eliminan los
controles fronterizos entre Irlanda del
Norte y Reino Unido para los bienes
destinados solo a la provincia británica
estos bienes Irán por Un carril verde
que será monitoreado por Bruselas
mientras que en el rojo habrá chequeos
aduaneros se mantendrán los que van a la
República de Irlanda que aún es parte de
la Unión Europea y el mercado único
europeo ahora básicamente se elimina
cualquier tipo de frontera en el mar de
Irlanda y esto facilitaría teóricamente
una mayor disponibilidad de productos
británicos en Irlanda del Norte Jorge
hablemos ahora del Banco Mundial porque
Calcula que los recientes terremotos
ocurridos en Turquía causaron daños por
34.200 millones de dólares bueno el
banco afirma que los terremotos
reducirán en al menos medio punto
porcentual el crecimiento previsto del
producto interno bruto de Turquía que se
situaría entre el 3,5 y el 4% en 2023
según el prestamista la evaluación
rápido inicial de daños para Turquía es
de 34.200 millones de dólares representa
alrededor del 4% de su producción
económica en 2021 pero no incluye los
impactos indirectos o secundarios en el
crecimiento de su economía ni el
terremoto más reciente hace ya una
semana se calcula que uno coma 25
millones de personas se quedaron sin
hogar debido a los daños sufridos en sus
viviendas los daños más graves se
produjeron en 11 provincias del sur de
Turquía que registran algunos de los
índices de pobreza más elevados del país
y también que acogen a más de uno coma
siete millones de refugiados sirios a
propósito de Siria el banco dijo que
publicará el martes una estimación
separada de los daños en ese país y hoy
volvió a temblar en Turquía y hubo más
derrumbamientos de edificios y de
propiedades hablemos ahora de temas de
la región Argentina recibirá 450
millones de dólares de créditos allá
tiembla es la economía del país sin duda
alguna sí lo anunció el Banco Mundial
que aprobó dos créditos para Argentina
según el gobierno argentino el
directorio del Banco Mundial aprobó un
crédito para Argentina por 300 millones
de dólares que financiará un programa
que busca reducir las tasas de abandono
tanto las escuelas secundarias como en
el nivel superior el otro desembolso
aprobado por 150 millones de dólares se
destinará a un plan para apoyar un
crecimiento urbano planificado que
permita un acceso más inclusivo a la
vivienda un análisis de GP Morgan
advirtió que la economía argentina se
enfrenta a la perspectiva de un
aterrizaje forzoso este año debido a la
sequía que agrava las expectativas de
una mayor recesión la segunda mayor
economía de Sudamérica se contraería
según el banco 1,7% este año frente a la
previsión anterior que era apenas el
0,5% y para el cierre hablamos de
Twitter más despidos bueno la empresa de
elon musk despidió al menos a 200
empleados más del 10% de su fuerza
laboral según el diario de New York
Times en esta nueva tanda de despido se
incluye a gerentes de producto expertos
en Big Data e ingenieros que trabajan en
el aprendizaje automático y la
confiabilidad de esta plataforma la
polémica se da porque mosc había dicho
que ya no iba a despedir a más personal
tras la primera ronda de despidos cuando
asumió la propiedad de la red social hoy
se conoció que elon musk recuperó
también su puesto como la persona más
rica del mundo después de perder
brevemente el título ante el francés
Bernard Arnold la riqueza de Moss fue
impulsada precisamente por un aumento de
casi el 70% del precio de las acciones
de tesla este año Muchas gracias Jorge
por esta actualización de las noticias
sean relacionadas con la economía a
continuación el debate
[Música]